[Música]
Hola soy Marina sardina y les doy la
bienvenida a Expreso de oriente en
magazine quincenal de France 24 en el
que les acercamos las historias de medio
oriente América Latina Esto es lo que
veremos en el programa de hoy las
protestas sociales en Irán ya han
entrado en su primer mes con los jóvenes
iraníes liderando y presionando en las
calles al régimen entonces a la brutal
represión de las autoridades de la
República islámica una nueva generación
que ha perdido el miedo a reivindicar
mejoras en sus derechos analizamos la
movilización de los estudiantes y el
papel de las redes sociales para
transmitir su reclamos seguimos en Irán
acusado de suministrar drones kamikazes
de fabricación iraní a Rusia usados para
atacar posiciones civiles
infraestructura en Ucrania Terán se ha
metido así de lleno en el conflicto
ucraniano con la Unión Europea pidiendo
sanciones contra la república islámica
y por primera vez desde hace una década
una delegación del movimiento palestino
jamás visitó Siria para reunirse con el
dictador bajar al Sad en el primer
encuentro desde que comenzó la guerra
civil Siria en marzo de 2011 un
acercamiento para el restablecimiento de
las relaciones suspendidas por el apoyo
de los palestinos al movimiento popular
sirio contra el régimen
iniciamos el programa en irán con gorra
capucha mascarilla así llegó al
aeropuerto de Teherán la escaladora
iraní el nas recabi allí fue recibida
con vitores por algunos seguidores
después de que el atleta compitiera en
seúl sin el hillab como marcan las
normas de la república islámica para sus
atletas en lo que parecía ser un signo
de apoyo a las protestas sociales que
desde hace más de un mes acuden Irán el
rechazo a la obligatoriedad del velo y
otro reclamos por los derechos básicos
el gesto de recabi provocó temor entre
sus familiares ante las posibles
represalias por parte de las autoridades
iraníes Esto fue lo que dijo
me llamaron inesperadamente y tenía que
competir estaba preocupada poniéndome
los zapatos y el equipo técnico Y eso
hizo que me olvidara de ponerme el Hub
que tenía que usar luego fui a competir
regresé con plena salud y me disculpo
con el pueblo de Irán por la turbulencia
y la preocupación que les cree
precisamente son las jóvenes iraníes
quienes están liderando las protestas
sociales que ya han entrado en su primer
mes los estudiantes desafían a la brutal
represión de las autoridades que dejan
más de un centenar de muertos y miles de
detenidos según las organizaciones de
Derechos Humanos el estallido recordemos
comenzó con la muerte de maxa Mini bajo
custodia de la policía de la moral la
ira por su asesinato detonó el rechazo
de una gran parte de la sociedad ante la
obligatoriedad del jillab como mandan
las estrictas leyes de vestimenta
iraníes pero los reclamos se extendieron
y los manifestantes piden también
cambios estructurales en la sociedad y
en el régimen iraní las redes sociales
han sido un catalizador de La Rabia y
una forma de organizar a los jóvenes
también desde el extranjero por eso el
régimen está constantemente cortando las
comunicaciones para analizar esto
tenemos con nosotros a Daniel banades
analista político especializado en medio
oriente Daniel Muchas gracias por estar
en francés 24 quería preguntarte qué ha
cambiado en la juventud iraní que ahora
vemos que está liderando las protestas
en las calles Cuál ha sido ese cambio en
los últimos años de Esta denominada
generación Z que se ha alzado contra el
statu quo
Efectivamente es una generación
postrevolucionaria que se ha socializado
bajo el régimen islámico de Irán y que
solo conoce una forma de socialización
no que es a través de los códigos
impuestos desde el régimen Esta
generación postrevolucionaria tiene
representa un total de un 60% de la
población nos de 80 millones que tiene
Irán y lo que realmente ahora mismo está
reclamando son más libertades más
derechos y sobre todo un futuro próspero
es una es una es un sector de la
población es una generación que ya no
está siguiendo los valores
revolucionarios que hay claramente una
desconexión entre población y
régimen estos valores posrevolucionarios
ya no están aceptados entre la sociedad
iraní la más joven y por ello demandan
más cambios y reformas sobre todo en
esta ola de
derechos sociales que vivimos en el
panorama internacional Irán no es ajeno
a estos movimientos y su población joven
no lo es y por eso lo están reclamando
también en Irán también Daniel hemos
visto en las redes sociales cientos de
hashtag con el nombre de Mini vídeos
compartidos a través de tiktok Twitter
Instagram Cómo ha sido el papel de estas
redes para extender estas convocatorias
y también para llevar los mensajes al
extranjero
claro efectivamente lo que estamos
viendo ahora mismo en estos movimientos
en las redes sociales es fundamental
decir que se están transmitiendo no solo
eslóganes no solo himnos pero también se
están retransmitiendo las represiones
que se están llevando a cabo en las
calles esto es fundamental decirlo los
eslóganes están evolucionando a lo largo
de estas protestas el himno también está
presente entre el colectivo más joven y
sobre todo la cuestión de la represión
Es cierto que
al ser una Revolución que está siendo
transmitida a través de las redes
sociales Cabe destacar de que el papel
de la represión también es fundamental
cuando los cortes de internet están
haciendo Mella están intentando cortar
el suministro de información van por ese
camino cuanto menos información Se tenga
sobre lo que está ocurriendo las calles
de Teherán o en las calles de ciudad o
lugar de Irán más fácil tiene el régimen
de mantener toda esta información bajo
custodia
Daniel y brevemente después de este mes
de esta represión que hemos visto pueden
realmente las protestas Conducir a un
cambio de gobierno o hasta cuándo se
puede mantener esta indignación en las
calles
es aún
hemos ha pasado un mes de todas estas
protestas ahora mismo vivimos una
situación de calma tensa todo es parte
de un proceso que hay que ir analizando
con el tiempo Cabe destacar que lo que
conocemos ahora y lo que hemos visto en
las calles es que hay una generación que
demanda mejorar su calidad de vida que
ahora mismo choca frontalmente con el
sistema político actual y para mí lo que
reclaman es una apertura libertad
derechos sobre todo derechos humanos y
una igualdad y sobre todo reivindicar el
papel de la mujer tenemos que estar muy
pendientes a las señales que se manden
desde el régimen que hasta ahora han
estado implementando una mano dura
tenemos que estar viendo también lo que
pasa en el contexto regional es
fundamental también entender el contexto
regional que se está dando sobre todo el
papel de Zuria es de Siria la guerra en
Ucrania todos son unos factores que
determinarán el desarrollo político de
Irán pero lo que está claro Es que esto
es un punto de inflexión hay una
generación joven que demanda cambios hay
una generación que realmente será el
motor del futuro de Irán y lo que
necesitan y lo que reivindican es el Es
realmente abrirse tener más derechos y
sobre todo poner fin a este tipo de
régimen Muchas gracias Daniel por estar
con nosotros en francés 24 y seguimos en
Irán porque las autoridades iraníes
fueron acusadas de suministrar drones
kamikazes de fabricación local a Rusia
los mismos con los que el kremlin está
atacando posiciones ucranianas la Unión
Europea ya emitió las primeras sanciones
al país persa que niega su implicación
en la Guerra de Ucrania nuestra
corresponsal en Irán Catalina Gómez
Ángel nos explica de qué tratan estos
drones iraníes en el siguiente reporte
la existencia de estos drones no es
nuevo en Irán vienen desarrollándose
desde hace años y muchos de ellos son
copias de drones norteamericanos que han
sido interceptados especialmente en el
Golfo Pérsico y que han sido utilizados
cada vez con mayor insistencia en
algunos conflictos en los que Irán tiene
participación como en Siria también en
Irak pero especialmente en yemen de
hecho algunos de los ataques Arabia
sauditas de territorio yemení por los
aliados de Irán los cutis han sido con
este tipo de drones Sin embargo su
incursión en la guerra ucraniana y su
venta de este tipo de drones a Rusia
pues lo lleva a un nivel mucho más
elevado y que ya toman una trascendencia
internacional el líder supremo en
declaraciones que han sido más o menos
ocultadas en Irán se burlaba Y decía que
las agencias internacionales en un
principio dijeron que estos drones
iraníes eran como juguetes y hoy día
dicen que son peligrosos sin embargo
Irán desde el lado diplomático
que hayan vendido estos drones para ser
utilizados en la guerra en Ucrania sin
embargo la evidencia quedar las fuerzas
ucranianas y otras agencias de
inteligencia internacional dicen que
obviamente Estos drones kamikazes son
provenientes de este país
y pasamos ahora a Siria porque una
delegación de jamás se reunió con el
dictador sirio pasar a la SAT para
restablecer las relaciones que cesaron
en 2011 cuando los palestinos apoyaron
públicamente el levantamiento popular
contra el régimen sirio que derivó en
una brutal Guerra Civil la normalización
de los lazos con al azar se demoró en
parte por el temor a una reacción
violenta de Los Seguidores de jamás en
su mayoría sunitas puesto que las
principales Víctimas de la represión y
persecución de ala-chat han sido los
sunitas jamás busca así aliados para la
causa Palestina frente a Israel Esto es
lo que dijo el jefe de las relaciones
árabes de jamás
en esta cálida reunión comprobamos que
el presidente alazad estaba decidido con
una firme convicción a apoyar la
resistencia Palestina y al pueblo de
cualquier manera posible
Terminamos el programa en Qatar
anfitrión del mundial de fútbol 2022
antes de que dé inicio el Mega esta
organización deportiva celebra su
particular competición la Copa Mundial
de niños de la calle una iniciativa
enfocada en darle mejores oportunidades
a menores en situación de vulnerabilidad
de 24 países de todo el mundo los
organizadores les enseñan no solo a
competir sino también a reivindicar sus
derechos en medio de las críticas hacia
la organización del mundial por
celebrarse Precisamente en Qatar un país
acusado de vulnerar los derechos humanos
Esto es lo que vemos en el siguiente
informe
sacar a los niños de las calles y la
pobreza a través del deporte a poco más
de un mes del mundial de fútbol que se
celebrará en Qatar estos jóvenes
futbolistas también son protagonistas
con mensajes que van más allá de las
competiciones y el género también
para ellos poder contar su historia y
escuchar las historias de otros niños y
relacionarse con ella es simplemente
alucinante es alucinante porque les abre
un mundo una puerta al mundo
como este grupo de chicas procedentes
del campo de refugiados palestinos de
tulcarem en cisjordania
el fútbol en general es una llave para
todo el mundo para mí puedo hacer oír mi
voz mis luchas mi mensaje y la causa
para la izquierda
también la sede de la cuarta Copa
Mundial de niños de la calle 28 equipos
mixtos de 24 naciones de todo el mundo
reúne a decenas de menores en situación
de vulnerabilidad con el propósito de
alejarlos de las precarias condiciones
que viven en sus países
a través de la Copa Mundial de niños de
la calle Deseo ver un cambio en estos
jóvenes como ser buenos líderes en sus
comunidades creer en sí mismos creen que
son alguien creer que no importa lo que
otras personas piensen de ellos que
sigan adelante para alcanzar sus sueños
devolverles la esperanza y formarlos
para tener un futuro más digno Esa fue
la idea de John Brown director del
programa que aboga también por el
respeto de los Derechos Humanos el
acceso a la educación y la igualdad de
género
cuando estos jóvenes se ponen sus
camisetas nacionales cuando escuchan su
Himno Nacional cuando izan su bandera
estamos increíblemente orgullosos de
ellos se trata de conseguir que el mundo
se ponga del lado de esos niños de la
calle una vez que Los ven de otra manera
una vez que los ven como Héroes el mundo
empieza a cambiar para ellos
también
un torneo alternativo enfocado en la
defensa de los Derechos básicos y por
ejemplo para el anfitrión del mundial
Qatar criticado por vulnerar los
Derechos Humanos
llegamos al final de esta edición de
Expreso de oriente Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos y los invito a enviar sus
comentarios a las redes sociales que
aparecen en sus pantallas y a seguir
toda la información en nuestra página
web
france24.com continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]